madame la ministre monsieur le président
madame et monsieur les présidents de
commission saisit et vous mes chers
collègues
vous dire je suis heureux de revenir à
cette tribune
pour discuter de ce texte serait sans
doute excessif
je formerai en tout cas le voeu que
c'est la dernière fois que j'ai à le
faire pour traiter de cette épidémie
le 27 décembre dernier le conseil des
ministres a adopté un texte qu'il avait
soumis la semaine précédente
au conseil d'état au parlement
depuis le 27 décembre que d'évolutions
27 décembre que savions-nous du virus au
micron peu de chose en vérité
le 27 décembre
que savions-nous de son impact sur
l'hôpital assez peu de choses aussi le
27 décembre et est il possible de
prédire que 15 jours plus tard
il y aurait trois cent soixante dix
mille contamination
360000 contamination et que pourtant
elle aurait un effet limité sur les
entrées en service de soins critiques et
sur les hospitalisations certes leur
courbe continue à progresser dans un
mauvais sens une force est de constater
que
la flambée sans précédent
de les contaminations par le virus du
coc vide un tas n'a pas à un impact
parfaitement conclu à quoi est ce dû à
deux causes
la vaccination d'une part avec le nombre
de cas graves est réduit et la nature
même de virus au micron qui fait espérer
une évolution fondamentale
dans l'épidémie causée par ce qu'on aura
corona robbie russe
avec cette possibilité qui n'est pas
encore une certitude
qu'après avoir évincé
le virus delta
fortement pathogènes
virus moins pathogène soit en train de
prendre la place et que
quand on a trois cent soixante mille
personnes dépistées qui hante un
résultat positif c'est là puisse
signifier que cinq cent mille voire un
million de personnes soit par jour sont
contaminées sans que cela produise des
effets sanitaires gravissime alors ce
texte
est il encore aujourd'hui un peu plus de
quinze jours plus tard adapté à la
situation et 12 en jugeront les uns des
autres dans les jours et les semaines
qui viennent
je souhaite que pour apprécier la portée
du vote que je vais vous proposer de
confirmer de sénart mobilise toutes les
ressources de ses moyens d'évaluation
des politiques publiques de ses moyens
de contrôle fondée sur la déclaration
des droits de l'homme et du citoyen dans
son article 5 et sur plusieurs
dispositions de notre constitution
pour vérifier
que se passe vaccinale aura bienvenue ce
que nous souhaitons une utilité réelle
pour juguler l'épidémie même si nous
savons que de toute façon il ne produira
ses premiers effets en faveur des
personnes qui se vaccinent on que
lorsqu'elles auront eu leur dose de
vaccin c'est à dire dans un mois j'ai
déjà dit que par conséquent il n'est pas
de nature à apporter un coup d'arrêt à
la diffusion massive
du virus au micro il est de nature à
protéger des personnes qui ne le sont
pas parce que nous savons que ces
personnes si elles ont
la chance de ne pas déclarer pour la
plupart d'entre elles une forme grave de
la maladie
peuvent néanmoins la déclarer beaucoup
plus que les personnes vaccinées le
sénat
a bien sûr exprimé des interrogations et
des doutes l'important pour lui c'est
qu'en contrepartie
de son acceptation du pass vaccinale
le contrôle parlementaire ait lieu je
suis certain que madame la présidente de
la commission des affaires sociales y
réfléchit déjà aux côtés de sur le
présidente de la commission des lois il
faudra que l'ensemble des groupes
politiques de cette assemblée puisse
s'exprimer sur les modalités les plus
efficaces pour que ce contrôle s'exerce
qui s'exerce sous le regard des français
et que dès la semaine prochaine nous
soyons en mesure nous sénat de la
république de leur apporter cette
garantie essentielle
les travaux en commission
mixte paritaire
ont été
ceux qui l'ont été
[Musique]
on
verra pas trop de temps ça je dois dire
monsieur le président
que de part et d'autre des efforts
considérables
ont été faits pour atteindre les points
d'accord qui avait été atteint et je
n'ai pas compris qu'un événement
extérieur à la délibération
parlementaires aient pu motiver
un constat d'échec
que rien ne laissait augurer
puisque nous en étions à l'examen des
rédactions traduisant l'accord politique
qui avait été non
l'assemblée nationale a souhaité
reprendre sa liberté
elle a toutefois fait madame la ministre
un certain nombre de pas dans notre
direction
en acceptant certaines de nos
propositions qui s'était traduite par
des points d'accord mais pas toutes
on aurait pu espérer qu'à défaut
d'accord formel constaté un accord de
fête puisse s'exprimer eh bien puisque
l'assemblée a retrouvé sa liberté nous
avons aussi dans une certaine mesure
retrouvez la nôtre avec simplement
l'exigence fondamentale
que nous puissions
faire en sorte
que
l'acceptation du pass vaccinale dans son
principe l'emportent toujours
sur le désaccord sur certaines des
modalités de sa mise en oeuvre vient le
moment où nous devons faire une
distinction entre un certain nombre de
dispositions auxquelles nous étions
attachés
et l'exigence de manifester l'unité de
la représentation nationale sur le
principe du pass sanitaires
cette disposition d'esprit qui est celle
de la commission des lois
n'a que 2 8 mais elles sont essentielles
la première c'est que décidément non
nous ne pouvons pas accepter une
disposition d'ailleurs en faux semblants
qui est plus une
disposition relevant de l' effet
d'annonce
qu'une disposition destinée à être
réellement opérationnels j'ai cité
l'article
sur
la possibilité éventuelle
de demander un document avec
photographies attestant que la personne
qui présente le pass sanitaire est bien
le détenteur de ce pass sanitaires ça
n'est pas que ce soit une bien grande
catastrophe
mais c'est surtout complètement dénudé
portait pratique imaginez que
les patrons du restaurant s'il est
obligé de demander le pass sanitaire le
fait bien sûr mais si on lui laisse
simplement une faculté une possibilité
une éventualité à l'ennuyer ses clients
ah non ça n'est pas ennuyer qu'on dit
maintenant
kittin &
enquiquiner ses clients en leur
demandant
à documents d'identité
je crois que on est plein d'illusions
disposition vide de sens qui n'a donc
pas de nécessité de figurer dans ce
texte et puis la deuxième chose c'est
que décidément nous ne voulons pas de
l'immixtion de l'inspecteur du travail
dans l'appréciation par l'employeur des
conditions d'organisation de son
entreprise nous ne voulons pas qu'il
détermine lui même la liste des emplois
télétravail à blé de ceux qui ne le sont
pas il y a déjà des sanctions pénales
pourquoi leur ajouter des sanctions
administratives
et tous les efforts que nous avions fait
sur ce point en commission mixte
paritaire ont été balayées d'un revers
de manche par l'assemblée nationale ce
que je déplore alors oui je vous propose
premièrement de réitérer votre accord
sur le principe du pass sanitaires à
condition que le sénat fasse la preuve
par 9 de son inutilité ou bien de son
une inutilité continuant monsieur
l'évolution de la situation sanitaire et
d'autre part que nous puissions revoter
les deux dispositions que j'ai cités
j'en ai fini monsieur le président merci
monsieur le rapporteur
[Musique]